notre panel politique martin biron au
christian dufour paul journet bonsoir à
vous trois bonsoir bonsoir crie un autre
je les ai cri d'alarmé en tout cas un
avertissement très sérieux de la part
des autorités à montréal concernant la
situation dans les hôpitaux jouf
entendre madame sonia bélanger la pdg du
sud du centre sud de montréal deux
extraits très clair on vient ensuite
donc on se prépare on va être capable de
donner des services pour le mélies pour
tout ce qui est excédentaire que j'ai
annoncée aujourd'hui c'est certain que
on est déjà informé le ministère qu'il
est possible qu'on ait besoin d'être de
certaines régions qui sont moins touchés
que la situation dans les hôpitaux est
extrêmement préoccupant qu il y a
plusieurs salles d'urgence à montréal
qui sont en déborde main la majorité des
établissements sur montréal sont passés
cette semaine en niveau auch les listes
d'attentes augmente il y a un impact
actuellement pour délester les activités
dans l'eau dans les hôpitaux
alors quand on regarde les chemins
intensif c'est là où ça fait vraiment
mal d'abord il manque d'infirmières on
est arrivé avec plus de gens en
choisissant ces faux québec que par
rapport à la première vague on va vous
montrer le tableau
maintenant voici 229 personnes sur les
1500 quelques uns martin c'est un encore
une fois c'est un casse tête énorme on
cherche du personnel l'ont dit on va
devoir faire n'est peut-être des
infirmières d'ailleurs la région de
montréal et on sait que c'est pour ça
qu'on se croise les doigts que
l'augmentation ne repartent pas de façon
exponentielle et c'est vraiment l'enjeu
du personnel qui vraiment critique est
très important lors de la première vague
le gouvernement avait libéré six mille
lits dans les hôpitaux pour la deuxième
vague
on en a libéré 2000 et on est rendu m et
5 cents personnes hospitalisées alors on
se demande où sont les quatre homélie la
raison pour laquelle on n'est pas
capable d'aller plus loin c'est à cause
de l'enjeu du personnel il y avait avant
la pandémie à peu près deux raisons où
on pouvait s'absenter pour maladie
d'abord on n'était pas malade mais on se
dit que l'art est malade ou on était
vraiment malade mais là il ya une
troisième raison avec cette pandémie
c'est l'isolément si vous avez été en
contact avec la coved vous devez vous
isolez dix jours 14 jours et quand on
travaille dans le milieu de la santé
mais ça arrive souvent
si bien que ya du personnel qui doit
s'isoler régulièrement plus d'une fois
pour une longue séquence et ça devient
excessivement problématique des
respirateurs du matériel
il y en a amplement pour répondre à la
demande mais il ya personne pour les
installer les respirateurs il ya
personne pour être capable de faire
rouler les différentes organisations de
santé
alors c'est ça l'enjeu principal on
approche vraiment de la limite rouge
l'on approchera de l'allumer tous les
capacités hospitalières n'arriveront
plus à suivre ça continue de ne pas
évoluer dans le bon sens c'est demain on
devrait avoir des nouvelles national
d'excellence en soins de santé comme il
le fait à chaque semaine devrait publier
ses projections et peu après le ministre
de la santé christian dubé va parler
donc on sera encore plus en mesure de
voir je serai pas vers où on se dirige
parce qu'on sait vers où se dirige
et c'est exactement là où on ne voudrait
pas aller on va plutôt en apprendre plus
sur la vitesse vers laquelle on se
dirige vers les scénarios les plus
inquiétants
puis pour le gouvernement c'est un défi
parce qu'il doit en quelque sorte tenir
d'où le message le premier c'est un
message rassurant qui fait tout en son
possible mais le deuxième c'est un
message alarmiste depuis parce que
objectivement la situation
elle est alarmante puis il faut
appliquer lio au delà des morts et des
personnes par l'aco vide de toutes les
victimes collatérales dont la commencent
enfin à parler de plus en plus les gens
qui ont des douleurs chroniques qui
peuvent pas être opéré des cancers qui
ne seront pas détectés à temps ou qui ne
sont pas opérées ou s'est rapidement
qu'on souhaiterait une minorité de
greffe qui pourraient être apportées
aussi on entre déjà dans la zone où ça
fait mal même si on n'est pas en vue
tout à fait dans le protocole là où on
fait le tri entre les patients on est
déjà dans la zone où est sa fait mal
concrètement pour juste pour les
patientes un lac au vide pour les autres
aussi oui et les autres que l'on voit
maintenant voter tellement pris dans
dans le feu dans l' incendie con oui on
savait qu'il y avait des gens dont lille
la chirurgie été reportée l'on voit des
visages envoie des histoires on lit des
histoires
hier on vous en présenter davide gentile
et ans présent depuis quelques semaines
qui sort du four tous ces gens qui ne
sont pas traitées parce que les hôpitaux
sont débordés ou et puis ça risque de se
prolonger au delà de la copie parce que
c'est comme un espèce de d'engorgement
de notre système de santé qui très
massif
moi je suis rappelé utah comment rapide
pour être franc c'est possible parce que
je me reconnais pas une grosse expertise
sanitaire
je reviens juste deux choses ça renvoie
le message aux citoyens
bon qu'est ce qui peut faire d'observer
le plus possible et conseillé de limiter
les contacts sociaux de contrôler leur
frustration à l'égard d'un couvre-feu
qui est contestable à beaucoup d'égards
non parce que c'est un peu ça est
hautement que je retiens c'est vrai on
est quand même en phase de
fonctionnement d'un système de santé
c'est ça le problème politiquement c'est
au départ le système de santé c'est au
service des citoyens vis là on est dans
une situation peu tard et vous on a
l'impression d'être au service de santé
et ça contraste je peux faire trop
disent nos logis avec le fait que le
vaccin est un miracle dans la découverte
de vaccin aussi rapidement c'est quand
même des escrocs privé qu'ils n'ont en
fait donc un moment donné va falloir
quand même se poser la question là dont
tout le monde parle mon open à discuter
comment ça se fait qu'un système de
santé qui nous coûtent si cher avec des
jobs avec des gros statut des gros
salaires énormément d'employés pas
capable de livrer la marchandise qu le
premier à le dire martine ces gens là
ont fait prendre conscience depuis deux
jours je pense qu'on est on est passé à
un autre
un autre niveau le d'anxiété on se dit
si ça devait parce que le vaccin tant
mieux mais ça va prendre quand même
encore plusieurs semaines
si ça devait perdurer qu'est ce qu'on
fait avec ces gens qu'on peut pas péri
qu'est ce qu'on fait avec ces gens qui
ont des douleurs à la hanche peuvent
plus marcher ça pose des problèmes
effectivement énorme
on n'est pas en train d' il faut faire
un choix mais on est en train d'y croire
angers les choses pour les traités ou
six pôles we say say say is on voit que
le milieu hospitalier se prépare à des
décisions déchirantes puis ils ont
engagé les protocoles mais bon du point
de vue du gouvernement
le défi reste le même c'est de limiter
autant que possible la propagation du
virus et d'accélérer autant que possible
la campagne de vaccination et puis en
effet c'est est révélatrice des
problèmes de notre système de santé mais
ça fait longtemps qu'on sait et le dire
aujourd'hui ça n'apporte pas de solution
immédiate à court terme pour pour la
crise mais
vous savez on prêt seulement parler par
exemple des cibles que le gouvernement
avait pour les attentes
tout ça ça n'existe plus et ses bleus
faudra les revoir parce que là on en a
encore pour quelques années une fois que
la crise sanitaire sera derrière nous on
en aura pour quelques années à essayer
de revenir à la situation d'avant par
rapport aux listes d'attenté je
rappellerai que cette situation d'avant
n'était pas enviable au contraire il y
avait il y avait déjà une grosse attente
qui faisait souffrir
concrètement des patients ouais c'est un
énorme problème martin bat les dossiers
s'empilent paul tout à fait raison l'est
avant la pandémie il avoir un test pour
une colonoscopie c'est en trois et six
mois
maintenant vous attendez un an un an et
demi les deux piles monte monte monte
alors il ya 140 milles chirurgie à
reprendre
combien ils sont du délestage la
première vague et combien de temps ça va
prendre pour remettre de l'ordre dans le
réseau qu'elle
quel défi colossal pour être pour
utiliser des mots gentils parce que
c'est énorme
oui alesi question mais non je te dire
que c'est un texte une épreuve
le système de santé on demande beaucoup
d'efforts aux citoyens papa le dis bon
c'est vrai que ça change pas grand chose
que de le dire mais il faut le dire il
aurait dit on qu'on leur tienne puisque
après qu'ali soit fini qu'on essaie de
changer des choses quand même l'ontario
qui annoncé hier des mesures plus
sévères
hélas les ontariens comme les québécois
une certaine période étaient mélangés
puis sont encore mélangé là est ce que
vous trouvez ça tellement plus clair à
noter un juge français avec vous pas le
tour de table il n'y a pas de couvre-feu
mais on dit rester il a même dit aux
français restés à la maison
c'est facile mais c'est dans les détails
que c'est moins facile parce que comment
vous jugez la stratégie ontarienne
d'après le terme couvre feu c'est pas un
terme populaire ni en français ni en
anglais car few monsieur faux il ne
voulait pas le prononcer pour appliquer
parmi les jeunes et les gouvernements
qui propose un couvre-feu importe
comment il l'appelle il y en a qui leur
rendent obligatoire d'autres premier à
dire aux gens à rester chez vous sans
imposer des amendes par rapport à ça bon
on peut l'analyser sur le plan des
différences entre l'ontario et le québec
ça a été fait moi je dis répète au
contraire que quand même certaines
ressemblances
on en comptait vraiment en du court de
moyens pour essayer de convaincre les
gens de les imiter leur rassemblement
on a de la difficulté à appliquer les
mesures actuelles puis un espèce de cris
de désespoir le prouvent refrain pour
comment non plus quand on l'appliqué
c'est ça que ça témoigne d'une certaine
façon c'est une puissance des
gouvernements qui ne savent plus quoi
faire et les intervenants peuple très
intéressant dénominateur commun c'est
l'impuissance finalement que c'est que
on répète mais à force de répéter l'on
sait plus comment dire ouais on est
beaucoup dans la micro gestion peu
surréaliste le choisir comme moi je suis
d'accord avec ce que dit monsieur ford à
l'école je couvre le couvre-feu j'aime
pas ça comme
symbole je pense que le roman d'amour
entre monsieur legault et monsieur forme
qu'on a observé un certain temps risque
de tomber parce que il a tiré à boulet
rouge sur le concept de couvre feu
monsieur fox
ça va quand même un peu bizarre d'avoir
deux provinces voisines qui vivent en
bonne partie la même chose adopter des
mesures qui sont quand même pas les
mêmes au sein de montre à quel point on
est quand même dans des mesures
politiques pour le dire et le redire on
n'est pas juste dans le saint père on
est dans des réactions politiques
différentes
ça relativise les choses que j'aime pas
passer la microgestion moi je vis seule
sa vieille cave cay est un peu qu est ce
que tu peux faire puisque pour faire je
crois qu'il ya une petite fille de 9 ans
qui m'a écrit tout à l'heure je lui
réponds demain la passe j'ai besoin de
sébastien beauvais mais elle me dit ma
mère un copain dans une maison x mon
père a une copine dans une maison y moi
je me promène en principe c'est ma mère
qui a la garde mais je vais voir mon
père est ce que je peux et elles étaient
mélangés personne ne pouvait lui donner
la balle quand on est la réponse simple
c'est peut-être le gros bon sens martin
aussi dire allez-y c'est beau c'est beau
parent allez-y moi je mets là moi j'ai
pas d'autorité je me suis demandée ne
pas répondre à toutes les questions non
plus moi il ya de la géométrie variable
d'art dans les consignes on voit bien
que le secteur de la construction puis
du manufacturier continue à appeler
régime le malgré le fait qu'ils
devraient s'y limiter mais le soir on
rentre dans un couvre-feu strict la
raison pour laquelle le gouvernement du
québec a décidé de prendre ce moyen là
c'est qu'ils voulaient avoir des outils
ferme ce à dire que la police peut
intervenir et données est pénalisée d'un
billet aux gens qui suivent pas les
consignes mais la police ne compte pas
prêt le monde dans les rues c'est sûr
que c'est embêtant mais aussi j'avais
bien prendre ma marche le soir surtout
qu'on attendait grosse journée de
travail
mais bonjour sport mais en même temps je
me dis que probablement que la police ne
court pas après alors il ya ceux aussi
puisqu'on vu que les gens suivent les
consignes alors c'est ça on est un peu
pris on est vraiment dans les puissances
les gouvernements tentent le tout pour
le tout il nous reste quelques mois le
finalement faire ces erreurs là la
campagne de vaccination devrait faire
son travail choix souhaiteront là
quelques mois
souhaitons le merci beaucoup je vous
demanderai pas de commenter ce qui se
passe aux etats unis une journée passée
temps mais je les dix ans des bureaux ça
va mal il ya comme une wii ça va il ya
comme une insensibilité je le disais
tout à l'heure
comme si plus rien qui nous surprend
deux fois deux mises en accusation pour
le même président le même mandat faut le
faire
ce n'était jamais arrivé dans l'histoire
américaine mais il est peu probable que
le congrès allait de l'avant après moi
je serais très très très surpris parce
qu'ils voulaient donner une gifle
aujourd'hui va partir les mercredi
prochain puis bon soin bompard à 0 non
christine sur presse on peut repartir à
zéro c'est merveilleux mais
malheureusement ce n'est pas si sûr que
ça ait des gens qui se disent que
peut-être un potentiel se dédire
j'allume de guerre civile aux états unis
ce qui représente 36 quand même majeurs
que c'est pas juste
je l avais besoin
il ya une raison sa présence parle bien
de raisons il n'ya pas pour rien non
plus il ya une raison qu'il ya des
raisons qui ont expliqué sa montée
camaia que j'ai put un paul désolé
garder pour la prochaine pour dames et
messieurs
on se retrouve au téléjournal ou demain
17h au revoir merci pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit